Were you very close to your father?
Yes.
It was a daddy daughter kind of thing.
Yeah, very much.
What was he like as a father?
Very you know, adoring.
Very sweet.
Lisa Marie
Presley was just nine years old
when her father, Elvis died
from a heart attack in 1977.
In 2003.
She told Rolling Stone
that when her father kissed her goodnight
for the last time,
she had a feeling
something would happen, adding
she was obsessed with death
at a very early age.
How did you deal with
all the attention of his death?
There was so many masses of people
mourning. That's what I meant.
Yeah.
In front of me fainting and carrying on.
And I.
I remember watching,
you know, as the casket was there.
They were coming through and they were.
There was a line.
And I just remember
sitting on the stairwell
not knowing what to do with that.
Lisa Marie was Elvis
and Priscilla
Presley's only child born in 1968
after her parents separated
when she was just four
Lisa Marie
split her time between her
mom's house in Los Angeles
and her father's Graceland estate
in Memphis.
Her childhood was far from perfect.
After she began experimenting with drugs,
her mother sent her to private school.
In 2003, she told the L.A.
Times.
I never really fit into school.
I didn't really have any direction.
So
music was her escape.
She went on to record
three studio albums.
Her 2003 debut
album, to whom it may concern
reached number
five on the Billboard 200
and was certified gold.
She performed duets
with the likes of Pat Benatar,
not saying
I don't think that's allowed me.
She once told Larry King
perhaps she was a bit
naive in choosing the same career
as her father.
I've been a huge music lover.
It's always had a huge impact on me.
I want to write. I want to sing.
I want to do the same thing for others.
Have my music,
hopefully do that for others one day.
Not realizing,
you know what I sort of had to climb.
I had an idea a little bit,
but I think that I.
I underestimated the whole thing.
She recorded duets with her father
adding her voice to some of Elvis's
earlier recordings.
Oh, please
help me get over it.
Lisa Marie told ABC
she inherited a rebellious side
from her father.
Alive and well in me.
Yes.
To the point
where my own children are like,
Mom, stop.
So what are you doing?
Don't say that.
You can't say that.
I can't do that for decades.
The tabloids tracked Lisa Marie Presley.
The tabloids have been rough.
They're rough.
They're really rough.
Her love life always grabbed headlines.
She was married
four times
She had two children with her
first husband, Danny Keough.
Then just 20 days after they divorced,
she said, I do to Michael Jackson,
the king of Pop,
when he wants to look into you
and he wants to intrigue you or capture
you or,
you know,
whatever he wants to do with you.
He can do it
The couple made
romantic music videos together
in stunned
audiences at the MTV Video Music Awards.
Nobody thought this would last
but the marriage didn't last.
They divorced in 1996
after about two years of marriage.
She married actor Nicolas Cage in 2002.
But they split after just three months.
She tied the knot with Michael Lockwood
in 2006 and in 2008 gave birth to twins.
By 2016 she had filed for divorce.
Lisa Marie had a theory
about why her marriages
didn't work out
as she told the Daily Mail in 2003.
It had to do with her own father.
I'm looking for someone similar to him
and nobody could ever compare.
He was so extraordinary, a presence,
she said.
Not even as an entertainer,
just as a person.
With her father's death,
Lisa Marie Presley
learned at an early age
what it means to grieve.
Years later,
she would experience
tremendous grief again
when her 27 year old son,
Benjamin Keough, took his life in 2020.
Last year,
Lisa Marie wrote an essay
about grief for People magazine.
She wrote in part,
Grief does not stop
or go away in any sense.
A year or years after the loss, grief
is something
you will have to carry with you
for the rest of your life.
Grief is incredibly lonely.
It's a real choice to keep going.
That's exactly what she did.
Keep going.
On Tuesday night,
she was on the red carpet
for the Golden Globes,
where the movie Elvis about her father's
life was up for several awards
What did this movie mean
to you and your family? Everything.
It just it's so incredible.
There's no words.
Lisa Marie Presley had a front row seat
to Austin Butler,
winning the Golden Globe
for his portrayal of her father, Elvis.
Some people wanted to put him in jail.
Joel's movie
and have you gotten to know Austin Butler
a little bit?
Yeah, I'm going to grab now.
Yes, a lot.
A lot, actually.
I adore him.
She was asked that night
if she planned to keep in touch
with Austin Butler.
Her answer was an emphatic yes.
But fate intervened.
Lisa Marie Presley was 54.
Joining me now, CNN entertainment
reporter Chloe Melas. Chloe.
What a heartbreaking week.
What happened with Lisa Marie Presley?
We just saw her at the Golden Globes
right before this happened.
Tell us about that and the
plans now to remember her.
Jim, I was at the Golden Globes.
I saw Lisa Marie.
And like many of the reporters there,
we thought to ourselves
that she didn't seem like herself.
We know
that a funeral details
are still forthcoming,
but she will be laid
to rest at Graceland,
where she was just earlier
this week,
giving a speech like Kyung
said in her piece,
to remember her father,
what would have been his 80th birthday.
And fans
were even
a little taken aback by her demeanor
and how she seemed.
Here's a little bit more of that speech
a few days ago that Lisa Marie gave
Thank you.
I love you.
It's been a while
I missed you.
And I love you.
And you keep saying
you're the only people
that you're bringing me out of my house.
I'm not kidding
you.
And I love you back.
And that's why I'm here.
So today
you would have been 80 years old.
It's hard to believe
Jim, she's spoken
about the grief
that she suffered
after her son's suicide in 20. 20.
She wrote about it
in an essay over the summer.
And she said, My soul went with you.
And that she never fully recovered.
It's only fitting
that she will be laid to rest
next to her
father and her
son, Benjamin, at Graceland.
And like we know,
we're all waiting
for a potential autopsy report,
but we might not get that.
We might not ever get the details
as to what exactly happened.
Jim
That's hard to hear.
And it's just difficult to reflect
on how much pain
this family has gone through
over over the decades.